five four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships christina ellis
best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money thank you for joining us
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five jared starts us off in
california this hour hey jared what's up
hey how's it going better than i deserve
man how can i help
i'm glad to hear thanks for taking the
call
so
my our little situation here is a
family's growing uh we have a three and
five-year-old my wife and i
and uh we just pretty much
like to move into a bigger home
uh we're in our first home that we
purchased
and just need a bigger home bigger
backyard
well i would say it's more of a want
than a need but i think you get it
so the question is
things that i've been kind of trying to
figure out
should we sell the current home
and take the equity and purchase a new
home
or
save up for two to three years and put
down five to ten percent
for the new home and rent out the
current home
or just work on paying off our current
home
as soon as possible roughly maybe five
six years
um and then save up for another home
to move into cool
what's your household income
income is about 160.
current home is how many square feet
18.50 how many bedrooms
uh
three and an office okay cool good
all right nice home
all right um
i don't have any problem with you i
don't know a would be my choice um what
do you think i mean sell sell it and buy
something else as long as when you do
that your payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage but that
move up that way you definitely don't
need to move out and keep a rental
because you're you know you're not
paying for it we don't believe in
rentals until you pay for them
got it
because we want you to have the margin
to do that um
but uh yeah i don't see anything wrong
with it as long as you can afford it you
have a strong income you keep it 15-year
under 25 of your income i think you're
fine but i mean there's also the great
feeling that would come with paying off
your current house does that is that a
big motivation for you getting
completely debt free to baby step 7
yes um
yeah i think what i struggle with
probably like most listeners is just
trying to
enjoy you know especially we have a
three and five-year-old so trying to
enjoy the next 10 years or so you know
um
and so i think paying off the home
we can do it and i like that idea for me
but i think that that would kind of
restrain the family a little bit um if
that makes sense um
well i like the idea okay
i'll disagree with that i don't mind you
moving up if you want to move up okay
and you
adequately uh or accurately quantified
it as a want and and it fits and and go
ahead and do a you know move up sell the
house and move up again as long as it's
a 15 year fixed and the payment's no
more the fourth now let me back up
though just as a statement to all of
america
the enjoyment of your 1800 square foot
home with two children in three bedrooms
and an office
is not about the square footage it's
about your attitude
you're talking to a guy whose parents
raised
a three-year-old and a five-year-old i
would have been the five-year-old in a 1
000 square foot home and no one at our
house in those days ever talked about a
lack of enjoyment
it didn't come up in the sixties
okay so enjoyment is um your mindset and
so if you chose to enjoy that and as a
part of your family getting that that
smaller home paid off and owning it free
and clear faster
than you will the larger one uh that is
a an issue of contentment an issue of
perspective
and but the square footage does not
cause enjoyment
your brain does
right and if anything i feel like the
higher payment potentially and the
longer trajectory to getting debt free
could actually
that could take some of your joy right
exactly like the more your mortgage is
the more you're gonna have to work and
make sure you're able to pay that
mortgage and you're gonna take a longer
time to be debt-free so it's like i
think once you have not a payment in the
world you're gonna have even more time
with your kids which is really exciting
to me so that's not to pick on you jared
i i'm going to go with a if i'm you okay
i'm going to move sell the house and
move up but while you're doing that i do
want you and i want to just take that
moment to create a soapbox because it's
something we've been talking about
around here a lot with the real estate
market going crazy and you know it went
up 32
in 20. it went up 18 in 21 went up it's
gonna go up seven percent this year and
probably about five percent next year is
what it's looking like and so
you and i particularly among the ramsey
personalities have had this discussion
of
you know this idea that you're kind of
getting priced out of the market and my
pushback on that has been that the yes
there is a legitimate thing a
yes that's true some people are getting
priced out of the market no question
about it but some of getting priced out
of the market is this idea that
you know the difference in a stat the
difference in the
average home in america today
is a 2 800 square foot two bedroom with
a skylight a jacuzzi and granite
countertops
the average home in america in 1962 was
a thousand square foot one and a half
baths holocore doors and for micah
countertops and there wasn't a skylight
and unless someone shot through the roof
and so uh
you know that that didn't even know what
that was and so uh
you know again there's nothing wrong
with having better things we're not
against having nice things but when you
set that as the standard for quote
enjoyment or the standard for this is i
i i can't afford a house could be
because you can't afford a house it
could be
because your standard of of a minimum
is so much higher
than any other generation in history
if you're listening and so it's some of
both that's going on that's causing the
people to be in air quotes priced out of
the real estate market you and i've
talked about this a lot right yeah
there's a lot of pressure especially
among my generation to have the bigger
house to move up like he said it might
make him a little bit happier to have
more square footage and it's it's fine
if you can afford it but just make sure
that you can afford it that it doesn't
delay your other goals and that you can
be happy regardless of the size of house
yeah
and
be careful of the language that you use
as to what your minimum is
right you know
well
yeah i could afford a house but it'd be
over there
over there
in that area
you know that kind of thing and so you
know in this county you can't you know
well you're right i mean when i was a
kid we knew where the rich people lived
and it wasn't where we were you know and
i knew we couldn't live over there but
we never really set that as a as the
minimum standard
of where we were going to be and we've
had this discussion a lot around the
office even because our offices ramsey
solutions are located in the wealthiest
county in tennessee in the 11th
wealthiest county in the nation
so this is a very affluent county that
we're sitting in so to live within five
miles of this office building where
we're broadcasting right now is freaking
expensive so expensive so i mean it's
out of control and so it's bringing up
with our own team members here this same
kind of discussion
but you know you can live over there
yeah it can work this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
guy is falling
have you heard that and people are
really angry about their they want to be
right about the world coming to an end
they're angry about it so hey listen
here's what we're going to do we decided
that everybody's talking about it so
we're going to talk about it we're going
to give you actual facts because we work
with facts and we admit that people have
feelings we just don't make decisions
based on those we make decisions based
on actual data
not fear because fear shuts down the
actual critical thinking portions of
your brain and then you start coming to
ridiculous drama-based uh conclusions so
july 14th we're gonna do a live stream
called uh the real estate
reality check it's completely free
george campbell rachel cruz and i are
gonna walk you through what is really
going on in the housing market today
with actual statistics and stuff
things that you you use if you're
actually going to do economics and not
just watch the news or worse than that
your social media feed which is well
known for their ability to predict the
economy oh my god really so we're going
to show you how to navigate this current
real estate world what's coming up in
the next three to five years what's
coming up the next three to five months
for sure
and uh with data charts graphs but we're
not going to bore you we're going to
laugh we're going to cry we're probably
going to piss some of you off but that's
one of our personal spiritual gifts so
join us it is a free night it is the
real estate reality check on july 14th
spoiler alert we don't think the world's
coming to an end
spoiler alert we actually can prove it
to you
uh spoiler alert
uh yeah there's problems in the economy
you already knew that we're gonna talk
about all of this stuff in a real world
way july 14th you want to sign up and
you need to pre-sign up that's how we
know you're coming it's a
it's a free live stream
july the 14th ramsey solutions dot com
slash reality check ramsey solutions.com
slash
reality check
jump in and we
will talk phil is with us in naples
florida hi phil what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help good me too um so
i am in uh
baby step four five and six and i've got
a little over ten thousand dollars in a
fidelity roth
retirement fund and
um just with everything kind of going on
our budget
is a little bit thinner than it used to
be with daycare and just everything else
starting up and uh well just gasoline i
filled up my car this morning about
passed out
well i've got a 2004 f-150 and so that's
uh yeah my raptor man i swear to god i
can buy a house for what i can fill up
the raptor for
it's weird when you're standing at the
gas pump and people are just yelling
biden randomly
yeah there's a lot of stickers around
here on the gas pumps too those are
pretty funny it does make it does make
the budget tight so how can we help
today
well i'm wondering um so with our my
fidelity account uh it seems that i have
to have a 2500 to open up another
mutual fund and so i have over ten
thousand dollars in one mutual final
large cap and
wondering
now that it's a little hard to save you
know twenty five hundred dollars should
i diversify that and put it into three
other
um
mutual funds so now i have the all four
that you guys talked about
um and it's a little easier i guess to
keep investing instead of now saving to
try to invest yeah you don't have to
have 2500 if you have it on a monthly
draft
and the easiest way to do your roth is
set your set your investments up on a
monthly draft auto drafting your
checking account
instead of doing it lump sum once a year
yeah yeah it just it seemed like when i
had started this it was you had to have
twenty five hundred dollars you don't
you don't not not to do a monthly draft
to do a single to set up an account and
do a single
occasional investment like once a year
you fund your roth or something in a
lump sum you do what you do with some
mutual funds 2 500 some are a thousand i
think there's two
or three that are 500 minimum some are 5
000 minimum there's all kinds of
different minimums but uh but yeah
that's what you're running into you can
set it up with almost all of fidelity's
funds
on a monthly auto draft it's an
authorization to draft your checking
account and it's uh it's easier on you
and it's auto it's automated discipline
as well
yeah for sure okay so there wasn't you
know generally that kind of situation
there wouldn't be
um taxes or fees if i were to try to
diversify
now you can roll it around among all of
those or you could roll it over to just
uh you know you can go get your smart
investor pro
uh one of the folks that we recommend in
that area and they can help you set it
all up and just put it on autopilot but
there is a huge advantage to doing
automatic draft on things that are that
that you know that you are that you want
to
create for me it's automatic discipline
because i forget to do stuff right yeah
and it's also just with the budget
getting tighter he was talking about gas
and inflation and daycare and all these
different costs having that automatic
pay yourself first kind of mentality
where it's like you don't have to think
about it you're not debating at the end
of the month don't have enough money to
put into it it's already just
there and going out it's just really you
will cut the quote disposable income
stuff so you make your investment yep
and you can still do that i mean so
because there's gas and groceries and
that kind of stuff have not gone up
enough yet to completely squeeze you if
you're at baby step four meaning you
don't have any debt
except a house payment
and so you've got room to do your 15
and eat
even though eating costs more but you
know you may not be going out to eat as
much you may be limiting a vacation you
may be limiting your clothing budget but
you got plenty of clothes and you know
maybe
one less six thousand dollar purse or
whatever i don't know but
uh
you know there's some other stuff but
but you're right you want to
force yourself when things are tight to
continue to be smart right take that
temptation away like take that you know
ability to just use it on something else
and it can be really real needs you know
you might feel at the end of the month
you know i have to stretch my budget for
groceries and these needs that we have
in our household but if you're not
seeing that money and it's going
straight to investments it's just you
know you put your pressure more on your
day-to-day budget versus taking away
from your investing and the way to know
that that's right is
you never missed a car payment
right back when you had a car payment
and so you know you can you know even if
cash prices went up you made your car
payment you figured you just squeezed
out everything some other stuff and
that's that's what you end up doing here
in these situations and hopefully some
of this inflation will
calm down particularly this stuff at the
gas pump eventually
it will eventually it's just a matter of
which politician susan is in boise hi
susan how are you
fine good thanks for taking my call sure
my question is about um
car repairs so we have a 2008 honda
accord that needs a new timing chain
to the tune of twenty two hundred
dollars
and the car is probably worth
forty five hundred so we can't decide if
we should do the repairs or is it time
to get another car
uh there's two things there that sounds
like you got a dealer price
uh
yes yeah
so you
you don't fix 4500 cars at the dealer
yeah well i take that back
the 4500 is no no no no no i'm talking
about the timing chain price
oh the timing the repair sounds too
expensive since inaccurate to me oh okay
i think you got a very high bid
like did you take it to the honda
dealership to get the repair done
no we took it to the mechanic that we've
used for quite a few years okay
then i may be wrong
i may be wrong but that sounds high for
a timing chain to me
okay so here's the here's the here's the
math here's the way you can the math
there's three pieces of information here
the vow or four pieces of information or
whatever but okay the value of the car
if it's fixed and running properly
is you're saying forty five hundred
dollars if you were gonna sell it
correct okay yeah the value of the car
if you sell it as is basically salvage
let's call that let's call that fifteen
hundred dollars just for fun
okay
if you take the
if you take the value of the cars as is
plus the repair
and it's more than
the value of the car after it's fixed
you don't repair it
and so if this car is worth fifteen
hundred dollars it's questionable to fix
it
if you can get 1500 or 1700 for it i
would sell it as is put the 2200 i would
have spent on it with that and go buy a
different car
because this is a huge repair so your
gut instinct was correct on this
i think this needs to go
but
if that if that repair price is right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
joining uh over a hundred folks joining
us today thank you for hanging out with
us we appreciate you dropping by drop by
anytime we got a great visitor center
free coffee free uh cookies and a debt
free stage where people stand to do
their debt-free screams and that would
be eric and linda hi guys how are you
good how are you welcome where do you
guys live orlando florida all right
welcome to nashville how much debt have
you paid off 237 000 in 22 months way to
go and your range of income during that
time uh we started at 120 000 at the end
of our
debt free we was 180 and now we're at
234. whoa way to go
excellent what do you guys do for a
living i am a payment strategy manager
for a telecommunications company
and i'm a national sales manager for a
access control
manufacturer ah okay and things are
going well huh yeah really good yeah
very good so what kind of debt was the
237 000 um typical you know average
american fancy cars you know camaro
tundra
and then um
timeshare and getting out of the
timeshare and
tons of credit cards anytime someone
offered us one we'd say sure why not
absolutely sign me up so you were kind
of normal very normal yeah normal socks
though
so you're dead free everything but the
house yes all right very good you
cleaned it up and sold it or whatever
you did all right so what happened 22
months ago that put you on this ramsey
journey why did you decide to do this um
well it's actually been about 10 years
of this journey but you know as the nerd
i tried to do it and he would agree but
he wasn't really involved and
at some point he saw
us put on a big whiteboard of our amount
of debt we had and the interest that we
had
that we've been paying on and i think
that was his light bulb that turned on
and we decided to start that journey
okay so eric what was it you saw on that
when that board when you went okay i'm
in
i saw those large numbers that we were
just throwing out to bank companies and
uh uh all the interest right so it
really felt like somebody was digging
into my pocket but you're working for
somebody else i felt like i was getting
robbed for so long
it just got me so fired up i said you
know let's start looking at this on a
week-to-week basis we started having
household meetings we even introduced
all of this to our daughter as well so
it just kind of made it a a crew thing
eric found a
villain get out of the villain and once
he had a villain he's like
a superhero that's it yeah that's it
so that's a pretty huge amount of debt
to pay off what was the hardest part of
this journey for y'all
i'm just keeping consistent with it um
you know i hate to say this because i
know kovid was a very negative thing for
most people but for us it was truly a
blessing because the first you know 90
days we were doing it but that's
typically when we tip fall off and we go
back to
using debt again so i think with kovid
forcing us to be at home forcing us to
make food at home doing things at home
allowed us to keep on this journey and
then become
it became habit for us kept you out of
the restaurant huh yes yeah okay okay
kept another shopping mall i became a
really good chef too
[Laughter]
i like it very good so for people who
are kind of you know in that similar
mindset they've got credit cards they've
got fancy cars they just are kind of
stuck what would you tell those people
that it wasn't worth it you know
physically i was sick almost on a daily
basis not realizing that it was really
due to all the stress that the finances
had and i don't think people realize
that we just go you know working our
nine to five thinking oh it's just this
is how we're supposed to be
but knowing that if you get out of this
debt that your
your life will be so much better we're
giving so much more now to other people
we are telling our story helping them
it's just
we feel much healthier now to be able to
do more things and spend more time with
our daughter as well yeah well done good
very good what did you sell
everything so really
camaro we sold the camaro
what else
we sold all our expensive cars uh what
was the other car
um it was the camaro the tundra and then
we ended up doing kind of like a
mid-sized car like average range cars
like a mazda and then we sold that and
then we bought you know a five thousand
dollar
uh honda civic you went all the way to
hooptie yes everyone knew i was serious
when i sold a tundra and i got a honda
civic because he drives the civic so we
always call that's we always say i look
like mr incredible getting into the
vehicle
we make it work he was a superhero
that's right but then we moved so my job
when i got a promotion we moved from
atlanta to orlando and so we we sold
everything in our home all of our
furniture and said we're just gonna
start over and once we get uh debt free
then we're gonna you know pay for our
furniture one by one bella's sleeping on
the floor i mean well we were sleeping
on the floor but we let her keep her
mattress
all right
yeah you really were i was exaggerating
oh my gosh
but you cleared it all yes and you can
buy more i mean you make 200 000 a year
and you know i mean payments now yes and
you have control of your money yes i
think a lot of that tea came from
minimal financial stress now where we
can
we didn't have to jump into a new job
just because i needed that paycheck that
immediate paycheck we were able to find
what we really wanted to do
for the next 30 40 50 years and what had
opportunity to it absolutely yeah
absolutely
and then we also had a side hustle so
we're both um we fought we followed you
obviously for so long and so now we are
life insurance license so and that was
kind of our side hustle to make
additional money of helping families
make sure that they are protected with
term life insurance as well yep very
good guys well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is sell everything
sell everything uh teamwork you have to
do it together although i'm the nerd and
he was okay with the process he wasn't
fully invested in it so you know
until that moment in january so i think
that's the biggest key for us is just
staying together always
having an open communication i think
that's really good for marriage too so
you know this is actually making our
marriage a lot better yeah i think i
think the weekly meetings too being able
to see those numbers because it got
addictive every time we paid something
off and we were celebrating every week
and saying okay we've got this much more
so it just kind of helped us to stay on
track yeah and then using your tools so
we use the every dollar app because with
kovid we couldn't use cash anymore in a
lot of places so just being able to
track our finances with our debit card
through the app you know we did
financial peace university and then we
with the help of our smart investor pro
we were able during the cover time
making sure that we weren't just paying
off the debt we saved a lot during the
critical moments of not knowing what the
world was going to be like and then at
one point we said okay now we can start
paying off our debt so just being able
to use all the tools that you have
really provided for everyone that has
really helped us wow you plugged into
everything yes and that accelerated the
process that's what they're feeling
that's very cool so proud of y'all well
done thank you who were the biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
um our daughter you know because she i
think she felt a lot of the stress too
because she's used to getting everything
she wants and you know we just really
focused on her softball journey and just
focus
trying to say hey this is going to be
our path you're going to have so much
more so our daughter our cheerleader are
really our smartvestor pro he's he
plugged in with us all the time just
making sure that we were still on our
journey sending text messages late at
night making sure that we stayed plugged
in so wow good for him
total accountability i love it all right
we got a copy of the uh baby steps
millionaires book for you that's the
chapter or the journey you're on for
sure you're going to be there for you
know it and a total money makeover book
which you probably already got you can
pass that along and another uh sign up
for financial peace university you can
pass that along it's a brand new classes
all the way through now and uh one year
subscription to that so we'll give you
every bit of all those things and get
you guys signed up and uh and or you can
pass them along so congratulations all
right your daughter's name is bella i
cheated and read that off the screen
over here and how old is bella 11. all
right way to go bella for hanging on
we're proud of you i'm glad they kept
your bed it's a good thing all right
eric and linda and bella orlando florida
237 000 paid off in 22 months making 120
to 180 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how it's done boys and girls
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight
825-5225
paul is in cincinnati hey paul welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hope you're doing better than
you deserve i am sir how can we help
hey so uh i've been listening for just
uh one week
my wife and i are actually on baby step
two right now um
we've got about 250 000 in debt about
130 of that is our mortgage we just
bought a house in april
the other 120
is
uh between car and student loans between
my wife and i
uh
just didn't know what the heck we were
doing when we went into school
especially me
80 of that
is from my student loans
been working in children's services for
the past seven years recently got a job
as a non-profit manager with a free
clothing boutique for foster kids
thankfully making a little bit more
money i've got about three or four more
years to go for the public service loan
forgiveness program and i'm wondering
is it
better to
try to get
actual forgiveness from that program or
start paying down those loans now
considering i've got you know less than
five years to go for it
well here's the problem with the pslf
okay
um
last year or since it began rather in
the last couple of years it's really
started kicking in
726 000 people have applied for it after
working 10 years
in a non-profit or a qualified area
right which is what you're trying to do
right 726 000 people have applied for it
all of them but 8 400 were turned down
so far
so far the program has a 1.16
approval rating
approval rate i guess is a better way of
saying it so what that says is 99 of the
people
who were on what you're trying to do it
didn't work
um i don't know how to say that anyway
except say that the government lied
because they uh you know they are
finding some reason
to not execute the student loan
forgiveness there's three types of
student loan forgiveness death
if you die your student loan is forgiven
if you your spouse or whoever's left
behind sends in a death certificate
they'll forgive your student loan it
doesn't pass right it doesn't pass on to
your estate it doesn't count against
your estate
disability if you become permanently
disabled and sign up for and qualify for
ssi under the social security department
then you can take that qualification and
have your student loans forgiven
and then there is a few actually there's
four types there's another type that is
underserved areas
and most of those forgiveness programs
are three years not 10. the biggest one
that everybody's plugged into is this
10-year program that you're in the
public student loan forgiveness program
and so far the other three actually do
work they actually do forgive you
it's a lot of hassle to go through it
but
so far the folks on your plan are at a
99
failure rate
and so if i saw that and i was in your
shoes i wouldn't be counting on the
government to help me yeah that's the
biggest problem is it's just not
reliable the idea behind it is great i
see why a lot of people feel you know
that they want to follow that plan it's
just like you said the numbers the data
of who've actually had their payments
forgiven that's just not showing up
nobody yeah so it's just not something
you can count on and especially since
we've seen so many people pay off their
debt by getting on a budget following
the baby steps we know you can do it
without waiting and that's a proven
reliable plan so i my vote is that you
take control of what you can control
and to start paying down the debt versus
waiting to see if the government might
forgive it and here's an interesting
thing almost philosophically that goes
with that that we do find in the data of
people who become like baby steps
millionaires you're right
your vote is is correct
the people who build wealth
control
what they know they can control
and that's the person in your mirror
in other words they depend upon
themselves
not an outside force to cause their
prosperity
and psychologists call that the locus of
control where is it you look
what source do you look to
to
cause you to do this and even those of
us that are people of faith we look to
god
but the you know but when you're a
christian
god says
uh those that don't work don't let them
eat god says uh you reap what you sow so
if you want some corn you should plant
some corn
god says you know you know the these uh
if you sow sparingly if you put out very
little work or very little corn you're
gonna get very little corn back and
these are very these are principles of
life that we see
you know agricultural uh analogies but
their principles of life and so this
locus of control this idea that my
destiny is most likely going to come to
pass when i cause it to
don't have control over all the
variables i can't control idiots i can't
control racists i can't control people
that hate people from the south i can't
control people and take people on talk
radio i can't control all of that but i
can control what i do
and when you have that you're exactly
right christina there's a high
correlation between that type of person
or the person that adopts that mentality
and the person that succeeds financially
so all of that to say
go pay off your student loans right well
and in contrast to that with the public
student loan forgiveness program even if
it did in theory work the way that they
said that paper that payments were
processed correctly there still are
things within that that you can't
control you could get laid off you could
change jobs you could move locations
we've heard some horror stories of
people who you know they did what they
were supposed to do for years and then
at the last minute right something
changed that they had no control over
and it disqualified them you know what
there is another type of loan
forgiveness that does work 100 percent
too and no joe i'm not joking it is the
if the institution like if you went to
one of these rip-off colleges and they
go broke
then they loan that that you took out to
go to the college that went broke is
forgiven and that's what's going around
right now uh joe biden just forgave five
billion dollars no it was corinthian
college yeah and uh it went broke and it
was a huge
huge scam
huge and uh a lot of people went and so
the this latest wave of loans that biden
forgave he didn't forget them it was
department of education by regulation
forgave it had nothing to do with the
white house it had nothing to do with
politics it had to do with that that was
already on the books if the college that
you go to goes bankrupt and you took out
student loans that student loan can be
forgiven automatically it's a regulation
it's not a white house dictate and it's
not a i get to say i forgave student
loans you didn't have nothing to do with
it
all right amy's in eugene oregon hi amy
how are you
i'm good dave thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
i have a question regarding an inherited
401k that i just received
my mom passed away 20 years ago and at
the end of may i had just received those
funds and so i want to make a smart
decision on what to do with that
why was it 20 years before you got an
inherited ira
uh she was
at the end of a very messy divorce when
she passed away i'm not sure if it was
finalized or
i mean not
just passed right
uh she committed suicide no i'm saying
recently
no in 2002. oh okay
well that money should have gone okay so
you should have gone to you immediately
it shouldn't take 20 years for you to
get it but you got it how much is in it
um
to date there's 113 000. okay i'm so
sorry for your mom i'm sorry honey thank
you a horrible thing to go through
uh you have on an inherited ira i don't
know if it starts when you receive it or
if it starts from death i thought it
started from death
which means the whole you have under
current law
see i don't you you're gonna have to go
get tax advice because i'm not sure
whether this started in 2002 or whether
it started now
if it starts now you got 10 years you
have to take out a 10th a year
if it started back then
it's on a required minimum distribution
process
uh and so you're gonna have to go figure
out since you didn't have control of
this when your liability kicks in
my guess is that i but i just don't know
what happened i've never seen one took
10 years for somebody to get it
so you're gonna have to go get tax
advice get in touch with one of our
smart vester pros i think they can walk
you through this or one of our tax elps
either one at ramseysolutions.com
because i just don't know the answer to
your question is what it comes down to
because the situation is so unique
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships christina ellis ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
825-5225
the call is free and some say it's worth
exactly what you pay for it chris is
with us in omaha nebraska hi chris
welcome to the ramsey show
hi there how's your guys's day going
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
so i was wanting to get some advice from
you um i'm in the military i've been in
about 18 years and i'm getting ready to
retire here in about two years
so with that being said my source of
income is going to be changing a little
bit
and uh
over the past year my wife and i we've
paid off all of our credit card debt and
our loan debt um
and uh
i think the only thing that we have left
is about 95 000 on a house that i just
bought last year
so with that being said
uh part of the way that i was able to
pay payoff part of my house it was about
205 000 i paid 105 000 down payment
uh i was able to save up some money
while i was out on mission
and
uh since my wife and i have gotten
married a few months ago
we have not taken a honeymoon or
anything like that
i was wanting to know if you thought it
was
prudent
to
save up for a honeymoon or some type of
vacation
um or if we should try to pay off as
much of the house as humanly possible in
the next two years
and then
go after
a later honeymoon after that is
completed
do you have a fully funded emergency
fund right now
um right now we have about two thousand
dollars saved up my wife just started a
brand new career a few weeks ago
and uh
she and i both brought her our incomes
together are about a hundred thousand
dollars
um
and she's working on saving up so that
way we can have
uh probably a four or five month
emergency fund and then after that we
were wanting to chip away at the
mortgage um so we're still a couple
months two or three months away from
that
um
after that i was just wanting to know
what you guys thought of thank you thank
you for your service um
well
what are you talking about spending on
the honeymoon
uh
we're looking at maybe five thousand
dollars and you're going to do that now
or after the emergency fund is done or
when when are you planning on doing that
after the emergency fund but i wanted to
know what you thought of doing it before
the mortgage i would or if we should i
would you would yeah
and that's that in other words that's by
christmas like this fall you go on your
honeymoon
okay yeah how old are you
i am 36. okay cool again thank you for
your service i appreciate that um
this is just the uh this is not the
financial advisor this is the old
husband that's been married 40 years um
it's a really good investment to do this
honeymoon thing
and it sounds like you all have been
working really hard the fact that you
put down such a big down payment you
paid off all your debts you've been
doing a lot of things right and really
committed to it so it's like once you
hit baby steps four through six you know
you're still working hard you're still
following the process but you can
breathe a little bit more you can take
that honeymoon you're going to vacation
exactly right after you've gotten baby
step three in place you're dead free
accept the house you have the emergency
fund four five and six just like you
just said is where you save up and do
some other stuff
uh and that means like that's where you
buy a couch or you go on a vacation
or you pay cash for an upgrade and car
or whatever it is you're gonna do all of
that after between baby step three while
you're doing
four five and six and what that means is
it's going to reduce every time you do
one of those consumption things that you
do need to do at that stage
it's going to reduce the speed at which
you pay off your mortgage and so we
teach you to be intense baby steps one
through three getting out of debt and
having the emergency fund nothing
happens there
no vacation no eating out beans and rice
rice and beans and once you move past
your emergency fund being in place you
move from intense to intentional
and that's what we're saying here now
we're intentional and that's exactly the
way chris was asking the question so
he's ahead of the game and i love like
the fact that he is so motivated to pay
off the house like don't lose that
motivation we're not saying that but you
can take a honeymoon breathe a little
bit but definitely keeping that
intentionality is awesome
jacob's in chicago hey jacob what's up
hey dave it's a pleasure yes sir how can
we help
yeah so um i
i've been really fortunate to have a
great career
at my young age through 28 but
i was recently diagnosed with a
progressive eye condition that'll
leave me blind in uh 15 to 20 years and
uh i sort of have a lot of financial
questions related to that but
specifically
how do i think about a 401k which
wouldn't you know pay me till my 60s or
generally get my affairs in order yeah
wow i'm sorry
you gotten a second opinions and
everything and you're you're working the
process i assume
yeah unfortunately uh second a third
opinion all said the same thing okay
so what is it glaucoma
it's called retinitis pigmentosa so i'll
sort of progressively lose my vision
yeah
okay
all right you've got a lot of
preparation to do that's the bad news
the good news is that you've got some
time
and you can do this so you're exactly
right you need to be funding something
um
in addition to or instead of a 401k so
that you can get to it because if you're
28 and we need the 30 15 that's 45 years
old you're gonna be 15 years before you
can start tapping into a 401k
so you really got to build up some non
401k investing some non-retirement
investing
um
and what i would do is sit down with a
smart investor pro
and probably redirect uh your baby step
four fifteen percent of your income
going into retirement um i i would just
redirect that and say it's not going
into a classic retirement it's going to
just go into good mutual funds and
here's the thing i want you to look for
jacob i want you to look for what's
called a low
turnover
mutual fund
all right
okay are you ready for me to teach you
for a second
yes absolutely okay turnover in a mutual
fund means what percentage of the stocks
in the mutual fund do they sell every
year
so uh one that turns over the stocks a
lot would be like an aggressive growth
stock mutual fund it might have a 200
percent turnover ratio meaning they
might roll the whole puppy over twice in
a year
okay you don't want that you want a low
turnover which by definition is a five
percent or less turnover ratio an
example of that is an s p 500 fund they
almost always have
like a vanguard or a fidelity has those
i almost always have a low turnover
ratio now here's why you want that
because then all of your gains are not
taxed until you cash it out
see if you buy a share of stock like
home depot for 50 bucks i just made that
up and it goes to 75 you don't pay taxes
on the 25 gain until you sell it
and since your mutual fund is not
selling any stocks inside of it with a
low turnover ratio
it's growing without taxes until you
cash it out it's growing a capital gains
rate like a house going up in value you
don't pay taxes on it until you sell it
same thing so the low turnover ratio
allows you to grow a capital gains rate
number one but number two more
importantly it allows you to grow with
any taxes on it until you cash it out
talk to your smartmister pro they can
help you get that set up i'm sorry
you're facing this sir
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
june 21st was ktar day in the state of
arizona as the legendary station
celebrated its 100th anniversary on the
air in phoenix we are honored to be part
of the ktar team
other affiliates like ktsa in san
antonio wmt and cedar rapids are also
celebrating their 100th anniversary this
year radio's 100th anniversary was
november of 2020 and uh we've not been
on the air 100 years yet but um but we
are uh celebrating 30 years actually
this week
it'll be uh the 25th which is i think
saturday won't be on the air but that
will be 30 years from the day i first
went on the radio
and so but ktar thank you guys and
congratulations thanks for continuing to
carry the ramsey show it is an absolute
powerhouse of a talk radio station over
there in phoenix and we love going to
phoenix for that reason we love all you
folks in phoenix we got a bazillion
listeners there and we're honored by
that thank you very much and
congratulations from your 100th
year wow that's pretty cool and no one
that works there was there when he
started i'm kidding
that i know of i'm pretty sure i know
most of those folks i don't think
anywhere that old so how many folks have
you out there stressed out about your
retirement you've looked up and seen a
bear market the scary bear is here
which means the market is on sale and
you have the opportunity to buy
something on sale you don't gripe about
that when it's a purse
why do you gripe about it when it's your
retirement account buy more it's on sale
you don't need it today anyway
ryder out baby but hey you got to have
somebody in your corner talking to you
that way and that's why we recommend a
smart vester pro they're experienced
investing professionals who will teach
you and give you perspective in these
scary scary times i am kind of being
sarcastic but if they are scary go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester you can find a smartmister
pro in your area to walk with you
through the ups and the downs and
they'll remind you that no one gets hurt
on a roller coaster except those that
jump off in the middle of the ride
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of window
custom window coverings free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
you'll save even more always use that
promo code ramsey it's a great american
company i love this company blinds.com
today's question comes from hannah in
new york our six-year-old daughter has a
disability in language delay with adhd
and autism i have a learning disorder
and was denied admission to all our
state colleges i do not want the same
path for my daughter are kids with
disabilities able to go to college and
if so how do we start planning now to
help her navigate any challenges that
would come her way
oh this is such a good question
well first of all yes yes they can go to
college absolutely
a few things come to mind in terms of
preparing especially at this age it's so
great that you're thinking about it now
one thing is to help her develop skills
so when she goes to college she's going
to be independent so starting right now
on those independent skills are great
you know work on starting and finishing
tasks following routines communication
and especially self-advocacy you know
helping her understand how to ask for
what she needs in order to be successful
and then when it comes to school you
guys obviously have a journey ahead of
you
being involved in the development of her
iep which is the individualized
education plan you know as a parent you
can have a say in that you get to be
involved with the teachers with the
professionals in the schools developing
that so you know be involved in that
process figure out what works best for
your student and especially as you get
into high school and you're thinking
about the classes that are going to be
taken you know make sure you're involved
in that process you need to figure out
what works and what doesn't work and be
able to advocate for that then in terms
of the future you know a lot of colleges
have really great
centers for students with learning
disabilities so you want to find those
colleges that have those specialized
centers you know some are going to be
better than others some are going to
look like they have a lot of
accommodations but they may not be great
so you know start exploring what those
colleges are and then ask them what are
the requirements for admissions and you
know what kind of classes do they
require and what's going to be needed
for your daughter in order to get in and
then kind of work backwards especially
when you're looking at high school when
you're thinking through that iep make
sure that the requirements are met so
that once it's time to apply for
colleges she's ready for that
and then also go to the colleges in
person because it's easy to see
something online and it's easy to seem
like they're going to accommodate your
student but get in there and ask
questions meet with the people in the
center and really take ownership of this
process you know it's a different
experience than in high school in high
school there's going to be a lot more
state involved requirements they're
going to be a lot more accommodating and
once they're once your student's in
college it's really going to be more on
your student and you to really advocate
and take ownership of the process yeah
if you plug into it in a good college
most of the colleges do a
a really good job
of you but you need to plug into the
center you don't just sign up as a
regular student and waltz around campus
you know you need to plug into because
it's built in the cost of your tuition
it's not an extra cost
uh so so plug into the counseling center
plug into the different areas there and
help them develop some plans around this
and obviously
wherever uh
she falls on the autism spectrum is
gonna dictate
whether she's actually gonna do well
academically at the at the collegiate
level at the at that level
and uh
you know
lots of people on the autism spectrum do
very well in college
but they're on they're on one end of the
spectrum if you've got an extreme
situation it's very difficult
and so uh
but all learning is if you're in extreme
situations so it can be done certainly
uh and there is a lot of uh built-in
advocacy systems in the process and
they're built into your cost of tuition
so i and i i can't agree more you gotta
visit
the the the school because here's the
thing
they can build a beautiful
you know center for whatever and put
people in there that don't care yeah and
it doesn't matter but they can build a
not so great center or have an old
building and people in there that super
care and that make all the difference in
the world
and so that's what you need to get on
and you won't you won't tell that online
you can you can breathe it in the air
though when you go in there and you look
the people's faces and you catch their
body language and do they lean in and
are they are they there to serve and
there to help and do they have a special
place in their heart for this and all
that kind of stuff it makes a huge
difference so um as you go along six
years old we may not know exactly what
you're facing
there's a lot of things can happen over
the next 10 years
and there will be a lot of things that
happen with autism and adhd over the
next 10 years and there will be a lot of
development issues with your daughter so
we'll see what where everything lands
but
yes there's a lot of possibilities there
and we don't just um
you know my uh youngest when he got
ready to go first kid when we put her in
school we cried and cried and cried
second kid we cried for a day or an hour
the third kid we just said college is
that way okay and you can't do that here
you can't just go colleges that way okay
you got to welcome in and through the
process and that will keep you from just
getting the door slammed in her face
yeah and i love that she's asking this
question at this age because it's very
very smart yes it's such good foresight
to be thinking through these things
developing the skills working through
the different ieps while she's in school
and then really being proactive about
the college part of things it's just
really going to set her up for success
very well done mary is in la hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
um
my parents passed away a year and a half
ago i'm sorry um i i just
right now um
my brothers
both live at their house and they're
going to sell the house and i feel very
excluded
and the whole process because
they are planning on selling the house
and they're
planning on purchasing another house
together
are they not planning on cutting you
a third of the house proceeds
that's basically
how they're seeing it um
are they i'm sorry are they are going to
give you one third of the house proceeds
no
they they do not plan on giving me what
makes them think they can get away with
that
so
when my parents passed away um
they passed away early last year and
then in october last year we we went to
the probate lawyer
and i almost
i out of guilt i signed over
like my older brother and i was signed
over a right to my younger brother like
to be basically in control of the house
no
no i think you need an attorney
you need an attorney and you're going to
step back into this um
they don't get to just decide this crap
that's not how it works in probate
there's a thing called law and even in
california they have laws
and so yeah you need you need a lawyer
right now this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt freeze stage jeff
and tammy are with us hey guys how are
you we are wonderful good welcome
welcome and where do you guys live we
live in a a little town in the middle of
shenandoah valley called stewart's draft
in virginia okay and what's that in here
it is near charlottesville
charlottesville okay wow wonderful good
welcome to nashville how much debt have
you paid off well we paid off eighty
thousand dollars cool how long did that
take about three years right at three
years good for you
and your range of income during that
time it was pretty much 86 000 for about
the entire time it's gone up a little
since then fortunately but it was right
at 86. cool what do y'all do for a
living uh we both work in non-profits
i'm an executive director of a small
social service nonprofit
and i'm a social worker ah very good
very good what kind of debt was the 80
000 uh dumb debt uh there were a couple
of cars
several credit cards there was even a
midlife crisis car oh wow yeah yeah so
uh that's what it was pointing at him
for those of you on radio yeah okay so
what was the midlife crisis car what'd
you buy uh cadillac xlr
nice i like it like it like it like it
all right so what happened three years
ago what was the wake up call and how'd
you get tied into this ramsay stuff
well we
have only been married for two years
okay we're on our second marriage
we were both in long-term marriages
previously
and um
he and he divorced in 2010
in 2016. and we left our marriages
with a lot of debt and no retirement
it was a bad situation and um my kids
were afraid we were going to end up on
their couch and they didn't really they
weren't looking forward to that so when
we met
we both had heard about the ramsey uh
solution that jeff was way more into it
and uh so were your kids pushing it too
no no they were just they were just
wanting me they're just worried about
you they were glad that i found somebody
to share my life with and i wasn't going
to end up with them
wow that's right wow
i like to say until that point my life
motto was romans 7 15 where it says i
don't know what i'm doing i don't
practice the things i know i should do
instead i do the things i hate and that
was basically how i was living life yeah
it's really time to change that yeah we
all have a time or two in our lives for
sure well done guys so eighty thousand
dollars that's a lot especially on
eighty six thousand dollars a year what
did y'all do to pay off that debt well
we sold everything we could out of the
house i got rid of just about everything
that we didn't necessarily need
we did the every dollar budget and stuck
to it
did not eat out at all
cleared out our cabinets cleared out our
freezer made sure we ate everything that
we could before we bought anything else
and literally just uh
cut everything in life that we didn't
have to have cut out cable cut out all
the extras that we didn't need and just
hunkered down and chomped those things
off from smallest to largest and it was
just it was fun yeah
way to go you know
very very good who are you who are your
biggest cheerleaders in this process
i think just each other and we really
didn't share our journey with anyone
um well the irony of this is we got
married march 21 2020. oh of course
i like to say we got married and the
world will never be the same
literally we were going to get married
in texas and literally everything shut
down and so as we were heading back to
virginia she was all disappointed
because she was like you know we we
cashflowed this wedding we have all
these things with this date on it and
she's on her phone and we wound up
getting married somewhere outside of
dollywood because you could get the
license to get married that day and we
still got married on the day we wanted
to
and then we got home and
everything closed up so that at that
point we really got serious about things
and decided we just needed to change our
life because our life was changing
around the ultimate honeymoon quarantine
yes exactly yeah yeah wow you guys
amazing very cool i'm proud of you thank
you thank you how's it feel to be free
it's awesome it feels good it's okay in
the past year uh being free from debt
we did a remodel of our kitchen we
cashflowed it uh my daughter needed a
car we cashflowed that
our air conditioner a couple of weeks
ago went out we did a grave service for
it it's 25 years old so there's no
fixing it uh when we get home that's
about ten thousand dollars that we're
going to cash flow that and we still
have our emergency fund so
life is different and you still got
plenty of time to build retirement yes
yeah and not be on the kid's couch
that's right they're happy and i love
that when the world shut down and things
are crazy and you're newlyweds that
instead of just being like oh like a
victim of it like this was a bummer
y'all pressed in and you went hard on
this debt that's just incredible what
would you tell people who you know feel
frustrated they feel like they can't pay
off their debt you know they're worried
about retirement savings that are in
your shoes what would you tell them to
encourage them well i'd say first off
the snowball plan works uh at first i
was scratching my head going but wait
i'm paying 15 on this card and this
one's only three percent and then i
realized like dave always says
at the end of the month when i've got
eight bills to pay and the next month
there's only seven that's really cool
mentally i'm only i only owe seven
people now and then a few months later
only six and i would just say it just
takes the time and the momentum does
build up like a snowball and following
the baby steps is the perfect way to do
that yeah
way to go you guys thank you and we
definitely
started communicating more because that
wasn't in a previous relationship so
it became fun to sit down and learn
where our money was going yeah and um
saying hey we have this and do it
together and we did it together and that
way and we're actually making progress
because we were broke before right in
the other place yeah so i mean we got
better marriage better financial
situation this is a good process yes and
i got to tell you now at the end of
every month when we do next month's
budget we're looking going well we've
budgeted everything and there's like a
thousand dollars left here we can start
paying in the house we can put more in
retirement and that never was a
possibility before it was i'm a thousand
dollars short where do i cut yeah yeah
most of your life yes right absolutely
how does that feel how does it feel to
be debt-free it feels great i don't feel
guilty getting my nails done anymore
get it girl
there it is ladies and gentlemen that's
the reason to do it
something i have never said
well done you two we're very proud of
you we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you we want you to
finish this up now let's go be
millionaires you're on your way yes you
can do this you really really can
actually it's very cool and we've got a
copy of total money makeover for you
probably give that away to one of the
kids and say this is why we're not on
your couch
and uh also we've got financial peace
university a one-year membership to that
and ramsay plus along with the every
dollar premium version and that's the
brand new videos in financial peace
university the class has all just been
redone it's the best it's ever been so
go through it or or send somebody
through it whichever one you guys want
to do we're proud of you heroes thank
you for control of your life you looked
in the rearview mirror and said i don't
like what's back there so we need a new
thing new view out the windshield
and you got it all the way across the
board a fresh start way to go thank you
good job
jeff and tammy from virginia 80 000 paid
off in three years making 86 000. count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
excellent job you two
man you get those nails done amen amen
amen
have no idea why we do that but yeah
amen
makes no sense to people like me but hey
man it's just something has to be done i
have figured that out after 40 years of
marriage so some things you don't have
to understand you just got to do them
china china i don't understand china
we spend a lot of money on these dishes
to sits in the cabinet and we have to
have a cabinet to hold the dishes that
we don't use i don't understand this
it's these are things men don't get most
men anyway
so doesn't matter you don't have to get
it you just got to get it there you go
happy wife happy life so there we go
what is the biggest benefit of debt
freedom i can get my nails done there
you go
i like it you got to love it though
that's exactly right i can live my life
without stress and guilt right because
people do so many things and then they
feel guilty people walk around half of
our culture with a financial hangover
they get up and do stuff the next
morning they go oh god what did i do oh
god
i messed that up they feel guilty half
the time they walk around shaming
themselves all the time instead of just
taking control of this and getting
cleaned up
that's why we're here boys and girls
we're here to help you
and sometimes that means we love you
enough to tell you the truth and it's
brutal but we'll tell you that because
we love you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jason's in reading pennsylvania hi jason
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
well i got a got a little dilemma here
and i'm trying to get it figuring out um
yeah i live with my girlfriend turn it
at the house and her son
lives there too and then he decided to
ask if we were okay with if his girl his
girlfriend got kicked out of his ever
house at her her mom's house so she
moved in with us and they you know i
agreed on like two or three months and
i'm figuring that wasn't kenny um they
bounced between the two of them and make
like well over 200 000 a year so i
really don't see why they just won't
just take that step you know and my
girlfriend
basically on their side and every time i
was trying to say something it's like
i get like the backlash and i'm like oh
so i just don't know what to do you know
they need to have that kick in the butt
to get moving but i don't know how to
get her on board with me and it's just
it's so frustrating so frustrating
uh
who owns your house who owns the house
actually we're renting the house we are
renting who's on the leash
um it's just her it's just my girlfriend
actually so it's hard it's actually her
house
yeah it's basically her house
when we got together she's allowing you
to live there
yeah basically i guess
legally speaking that's what's
but she's allowing it she's the she's
the least per on the leash she's in
charge yeah yeah okay yeah and so um
how how long have you been there
uh two years now okay and uh how old is
her son
26.
and the girl his girlfriend is 20 and he
was there before you got there
yeah yeah he said he was going to be
leaving a year after he
graduated from his schooling and got his
studio it's been
over a year now and it's just there's no
exit plan at all i'm like well what do
we do here you know
okay um
[Applause]
the only way the only way i know how to
answer questions on this show is to tell
you what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes but i wouldn't wake up in your
shoes so because i wouldn't have made
these decisions
um
so i think i've just gotta backtrack and
go okay
i think what we've gotta decide here i
don't think you're gonna get between
this lady and her
son when you are the boyfriend that is
not on the lease
yeah yeah you're not exactly in a
position of power relationally or
legally
and so i think maybe you've got to
decide if this is a permanent
relationship or not
oh i'm i was more than i mean that's
what that's what the plan was
okay then if we're going to get married
then it's a different set of rules
oh yeah that was already in the play
well no no i mean
you know i think that's part of the
discussion here it's like honey okay
we're going to set a date
and you know
now if we're going to set a date now
we've got to go into pre-marriage
counseling and part of pre-marriage
counseling is how we deal with
uh extended family which is grown kids
parents in-laws cousins that are crazy
whatever yeah and if you don't have a
plan as a couple to stay unified while
you deal with extended family in other
words she believes you deeply love her
son and want what's best for him
and she does too
and we're going to treat them as 26 year
old adults that make 200 000 a year then
then you can do that as a husband and
wife and you need to be unified on that
before you become husband and wife
and um then that's also going to change
the status of the lease as well
because now we're both going to be
husband and wife on the house that we
rent as a couple
now he's just trespassing once you make
that change
but right now you may be trespassing
you're both you're both there with her
at with her agreement but she's in
charge of this right now
yeah yeah
you don't have much you don't have much
of a ground to argue from right now so
um you know i i think you're gonna have
to you know turn up the heat on
progressing this
relationship and causing it to become a
marriage
and as a part of that deal with this
situation because i don't think there's
a chance in the current scenario that
you're gonna get between her and her
baby boy
well yeah i'm not trying to get between
he's like yeah we are i
wow i just keep getting different
stories
if i were you i'd be trying to get
between her because he needs to get his
butt out of there and be a man
but you're not in a position to cause
this to happen because right now you're
you're just a trespasser
yeah
i know what you're saying i understand
it from that aspect yeah they just like
keep hearing different stories you know
like they're saying per house
i don't i don't think you i don't think
you're gonna change the narrative here
because you don't have any influence
she he has way more influence with her
right now than you do
yeah that's my yeah it doesn't seem that
way that's my problem yeah that's a
relationship problem and some of that is
based on the fact that you moved into
her house
and you are not married
and so it changes the dynamic of the
relationship it's just the reality of
the process it changes the legality of
it but it also changes the dynamic of
how the relationship functions because
relationships are about
um
or one not about but one of the things
relationships are about is power
and who has it and who's uh going to
hand it over and back and forth so you
know in a good healthy marriage there's
a give and take of power
um you know we laugh and say you know my
wife wants to get her nails done i don't
understand but she goes against it done
but that's a giving up of power there's
a different you know and so i choose to
serve my wife but that's a handing of
power she chooses to make me dinner
that's a handing of power she you know
she's serving we all are giving you know
these are power transfers and you're in
a powerless
position
yeah that's good that's really good i
think especially approaching it from a
marriage perspective and just a
relational perspective i have a lot of
questions with the relationship with the
um the sun and kind of the resistance to
that but i think you're right to first
kind of deal with it directly with the
girlfriend and kind of work on that
relationship first because that
narrative between her and him that's
seems to go pretty deep
yeah
i mean
there's you know we're perpetuating
stupid ideas here
is what it amounts to um but you're not
in a position to do anything about it
right now so you're gonna either have to
get in a position of
power so that you can be gentle and kind
because you really can't be gentle and
kind when you're weak
it causes you to thrash about
and i remember one time when uh rachel
was a brand new baby
we looked up and her toddler sister was
carrying her down the stairs
and we about had a heart attack because
this is an accident looking for a place
to happen point being the weak can't
carry the weak
the strong should can carry the weak
that's you know you can't do it from a
position of weakness and so you can't be
kind and gentle from a position of
weakness you can't be um can't carry a
newborn down the stairs when you're
virtually newborn yourself
and so you know the you have to get
yourself uh financially in a position
relationally in a position
and
legally in a position where you can be
kind and gentle to this young man then
you can put your arm around him and you
know whisper in his ear and kick his
little butt and get him out he makes 200
000 views 26 years old time to get on
with it boy
be a man step up
step out but you can't do that when
you're the move-in boyfriend it don't
work
it just you don't have the leverage
you're not in a position sorry
and uh it's good it's a good question
it's an interesting discussion but it's
uh it's one of the dynamics that we face
in our culture today
um because there's a one thing we face
you and i face all the time we're trying
to answer questions for people that are
shacking up on how to handle money like
a married couple when they're not a
married couple because you really can't
you're really roommates legally
relationally spiritually you know you're
still fighting over who bought the
mustard
like you're like you had a roommate in
college you know that's my master and
that's your mustard you bought that
mustard didn't you and why can i have
some of your mustard you know you're
doing all this crap you don't do that
when you're married you don't have my
mustard your mustard it's just our
mustard when you're married you know and
where's our mustard you know it's not
like where's my mustard you know it's
just
i'm standing looking at the door and
it's right there but i can't see it this
is a husband thing right but the uh
all of that to say it's very difficult
to do things in a way when you're not
that thing
right and
that's that's what we process here and
there's all kinds of data to back this
up it's not just an uh an old fart with
a moral statement you know there's stuff
going on here
so i love that perspective too in the
illustration with the baby carrying the
baby like you got to be strong to be
able to help other people and be able to
speak into their lives on that level
exactly
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships i'm dave ramsey my co-host
today best-selling author and ramsey
personality christina ellis joins me
this is a baby steps millionaire theme
hour if you are a millionaire we want to
talk to you regardless of how you got
there or where the money came from we
want to teach america where millionaires
come from
for real not what your broke
brother-in-law's opinion is but what is
where do millionaires really
come from and christina we started doing
this female we're going to talk to real
millionaires if you have a net worth of
over a million dollars we want to talk
to you the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
not gonna talk to you this hour unless
you're a millionaire we wanna hear how
you did it and what your story is and we
don't really care what the back story is
we want to know because we want you to
teach america where millionaires come
from and this started happening
christine because i knew that there was
a bunch of mythology out there
floating around that all millionaires
become millionaires because they're
crooks
all millionaires become millionaires
because they're rock stars or
professional athletes
all millionaires become millionaires
because they inherit their money
all of these are lies
statistically now some millionaires are
crooks
some millionaires are professional
athletes and rock stars some
millionaires inherited their money but
the vast majority are none of those
and we set out to prove that by talking
to real millionaires and we've proven it
then we went on and did a study uh the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in north america a few years ago here at
ramsey and uh it has become quite the
thing uh because we have over 10 000
millionaires that we've interviewed in
detail on how they got there what they
did what their likes dislikes are why
what they attribute their financial
success to
and uh you know that is
the white paper of that study is in the
back matter of the number one bestseller
baby steps millionaires because i kept
running into people who followed the
baby steps and became millionaires so i
got tired of hearing all these whiners
these uh little men can't get ahead
victim people out there in america
saying you can't do it america's too
broken you can't do it yeah america's
broken there's a lot of stuff broken uh
but you can still do it
and so you just gotta decide to and you
gotta decide that it can happen but once
you decide it can't happen then 100 of
the time it won't happen
very true yeah and i think that this is
such a great hour and great example
because i feel like the myths are
especially prevalent with my generation
a lot of people are seeing the computer
rock star that becomes a millionaire
overnight and they think if i don't
become successful like instantly with
some type of thing that makes me rich
super quick then it's not a coin or
nothing down real estate you fall for
get rich quick if you don't understand
where millionaires really come from
right almost none of them follow any of
that exactly and seeing our millionaire
study it's like wait a minute that's not
true like a lot of these people are just
consistently investing and they're being
diligent and it's it's powerful let's
talk to our first one amy is in albany
new york amy what's your net worth
hi dave it's 1.25 million good for you
way to go give me a little breakdown on
the mix of that how much of that is
retirement how much is real estate how
much is whatever
yeah so 500 in our retirement 400 in our
home equity
150 and non-retirement and 200 in cash
all right okay investments and 200 in
cash way to go how old are you
34. young millionaire very good
and how much of this 1.25 did you guys
inherit
maybe 1500 when i was 18.
okay so it's safe to say mathematically
you are not a millionaire because of
inherited money
correct and what is your income and best
year and worst year since you started
working household income
so when i graduated i started out at 63
000 and then last year my husband and i
uh gross 600 000 yo
what do you guys do for a living
um so i'm an engineering manager and my
husband runs an insurance business he's
self-employed you guys are doing very
well okay so part of the reason you did
this by 34 is you make an outrageously
wonderful income congratulations
yeah thank you what else would you
attribute the fact that you're a
millionaire by 34 to just the fact that
you made a lot of money or what
no i mean um
so when we got married three years ago
our net worth was probably around
600 000 and and i would attribute you
know getting that far to just
consistently saving money for retirement
just like you said a few minutes ago
uh being diligent with it and and you
know staying out of debt as well yeah
what's your degree in
um my degree is in biomedical
engineering okay and what was your gpa
3.73 okay all right cool all right and
um
oops get that back okay cool
so
somebody that's 24 and listening what
would you tell them they need to do go
get a six hundred thousand dollar your
income yeah that would help you
but other than that what would you tell
them to do
yeah i would first of all uh thank my
parents they
gave me the two biggest lessons uh that
impacted my financial life personally
which is making sure i graduated from
college completely debt-free
and they also introduced me to your
principals you know when i was 20 years
old um so i guess you could say i drink
the kool-aid pretty young
and i've been following that ever since
so you are a baby steps millionaire in
that sense
correct yeah so did you set this goal
early on that you wanted to be a
millionaire by your mid-thirties or was
this something that you just kind of
were consistent and then woke up one day
and you're like wow we're getting close
like what did this journey look like for
you
the goal wasn't necessarily to be a
millionaire i just
i know reading dave's books and you know
listening to his radio show and his
podcast hearing the pain in people's
voices of um you know being tied to
their debt i never wanted to experience
that so
my priority financially you know when i
was single and then being married is
never to use debt um in any way i mean
we have a mortgage but that's it okay so
amy you're 34 you have a 1.25 million
net worth congratulations uh last
question before i'll let you go how much
of this did you steal
nothing
thanks for calling in hero just want to
make sure you're not a crook because
everybody knows that rich people are all
crooks that's how they got to be rich
right isn't this the stupid butt stuff
people say all the time that's crazy
isn't it funny and yet we talked to
sweet law amy who's just been doing dave
ramsey stuff since she was 20. that's
all she did and she went and they got a
great income so they they're they
cheated on the income by the way because
the typical millionaire in our study
33 of them one-third of the ten thousand
never had a household income over a
hundred
and they still became millionaires so
you don't have to have six hundred
thousand dollar income but wow way to go
i'm so proud of amy and her husband
they're killing it and oh the other one
is there's millionaires if you can't be
a millionaire if you're not like super
smart
now she is a bio engineer i mean so
she's not dumb and she does have a 3.7
gpa in college she's not dumb but it won
a 4.2
she didn't graduate valedictorian with
that 3-7 i can tell you that no she just
found a process she worked it she was
consistent i you know i'm worth several
hundred million my gpa was 2.97 i'm
still pissed about that three one
hundredths of a point
um something about fear involved in that
i think i could be wrong but it's
possible
uh
it's a millionaire of baby steps
millionaires theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires this hour on the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaire theme hour
this is the ramsey show if you want to
talk about building wealth we're going
to talk about it we have four live
events in the fall in your city well at
least four of your cities and uh it will
be george campbell dave ramsey rachel
cruz dr john deloney and ken coleman
will be signing books taking pictures
and doing an event called building
wealth where we teach you the real steps
to building wealth so you can be a baby
steps millionaire right i will be in
phoenix september the 13th sacramento
november the 1st minneapolis november
the 10th and san antonio november the
15th
you can get your tickets for 25 or a
four pack starting as low as 60 so bring
a bunch of friends
come out it's a great night these are
usually a tuesday thursday night
something like that they're almost sold
out they're all in the 90 percentile
sold out so they have a handful of
tickets each i know they're out in
september and november but if you want
tickets i suggest you go ahead and get
them
now especially given the tickets aren't
very expensive go to ramseysolutions.com
events and check that out you can also
check out the
october 22nd dallas smart conference
tickets are on sale there as well it is
a millionaires only hour this hour we're
talking to real millionaires finding out
how they did it mike is in denver mike
what's your net worth
about 1.6 million dave cool give me a
little breakdown on that by category
please how much retirement real estate
so on
well the house is worth about 700 with a
mortgage of about 350.
and i've got a rollover ira worth about
700
and
roth and brokerage that are smaller than
that but total about 500.
good very good okay cool
and uh how old are you
i'm 59. okay good and how much of the
1.6 did you inherit
a can of steel cut oats and a 10 pound
bag of pinto beans
it sounds like my family
got it and uh in your working lifetime
what was your all's beginning or worst
year of income and your best year of
income what's the range
um about 65k to 160k
cool and what was your career or is your
career
uh i'm an engineer okay
all right
and uh what was your gp i assume you
have a degree in engineering
yes i do okay and what was your gpa
uh 3.8 good for you cool all right and
what do you attribute the fact that
you're not 60 years old yet and you are
worth almost 2 million dollars
why
live beneath your means
and uh
you'll find that if you put away 100 or
200 bucks every month that uh
when when you're busy and not looking
it'll grow into some some substantial
savings
any other advice other than that that
you'd have for the 25 year old engineer
that's listening right now
um
not a whole lot i can't see anything
wrong with thrift as a day-to-day
piece of advice have you enjoyed money
though while you're going along or were
you just a tight wad
well
you know some people think i'm a taiwan
one of my sisters does but i think i've
enjoyed the money
we just all enjoy money a little
differently i buy tools to fix my car
what's the most expensive thing you've
ever bought
well i guess uh
you know i bought a brand new car
back in 2005 and it was about 28 or 29
000. um okay what's the most expensive
trip you've ever been on
uh
i went to tahiti with my zen newlywed
wife nah that cost us a few thousand
dollars i bet
it's lovely
what were there any major challenges you
faced along the way or something you
wish you would have known sooner
um
you know uh
i don't think
my challenges were really substantially
different from the ones that anyone else
faces you know there's unexpected
layoffs and unexpected expenses
and if you've
if you've built an emergency fund though
i didn't call it that by that name back
then what'd you call it
um it was just savings in case something
bad happens okay
all right that works yeah i didn't run
across your program until two or three
years ago
right but
you know like uh you know if you own a
house your water heater is going to go
out or if you own a car your
transmission is going to go out one of
these things is going to happen you just
don't know when
and if you have if you have some savings
then this is really inconvenient
but it won't kill you but if you don't
have any savings it could be cataclysmic
yeah absolutely absolutely
well done mike good good call man thank
you for sharing your your story with us
your hero we're proud of you don is in
st louis don what's your net worth
uh 1.76 million cool and give me a
little breakdown by category on that
please
well our retirement accounts uh we have
in the
in the neighborhood of right out a
million uh the house is around 480 000.
we have about 130 000 in in cash
and then we have a 529 account
with a little over 45 000 in it got it
cool all right how old are you
48. good good and how much of the 1.76
is there from inheritance
i did inherit 25 000 from my my
grandmother uh but i
i i took that paid off the loan i had on
my truck and then i paid myself back
okay and the uh how long ago was that
that was probably 15 years ago okay
do you think that's why you're a
millionaire
the inherited money no
no no way okay
mathematically it wouldn't be but i'm
just double checking okay
and uh so what's your best year of
income household income and your worst
year of household income since you guys
have been working
uh best or
worst year probably a hundred thousand
and i would say our best year is
probably going to be this year
uh probably top out around 210 000.
excellent good what's your career
i am an industrial hygienist okay
all right
and uh what's your degree in
industrial hygiene go go figure yeah
okay
and what was what was your what was your
gpa
uh my gpa was a 3.68 and my wife she is
she's a teacher hers was a 4.0 ah okay
all right and a teacher good all right
all right so she's the smart one of the
bunch huh
uh yeah
[Laughter]
all right what advice have you got for
the 24 year old out there listening to
us right now
i would tell them that
plan
stay on top of it
be patient
and don't worry about what the joneses
have
what's the dumbest thing you did with
money in your life
bought some cryptocurrency
[Laughter]
you did that recently
[Laughter]
yeah and it's worth absolutely nothing
how much did you lose
i i it's a couple hundred bucks but
um you know it's more or less play money
yeah but uh you know it
you know when you lose it it hurts yeah
it hurts your pride psychological
it does it does it hurts your pride but
you know i've probably done other dumb
things probably
by something that i didn't necessarily
need or or
i don't know there's there's probably
other done things that i've done i got
you okay
are you guys uh
are you readers or are you tv people
i would say we're more tv people okay
cool good good what would you say is
your biggest key to success in this
the biggest key
is you have to plan
this is not something that you have to
it doesn't happen overnight you know if
you take back and you look at our story
here this has been going on for 22 years
yeah and yeah it started out small
and and it's grown and it's grown but if
we didn't sit down and plan it out and
think about what we wanted to be in in
20 or 30 years or maybe even 40 years
it's never going to happen
absolutely
hey thanks for sharing your story you're
a hero in other words you don't win on
accident
winning is not an accidental act it is
an intentional act
i love it don thank you for sharing it's
a baby steps millionaires theme hour
here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour thank you for joining us we're
talking to real millionaires this hour
someone that has a net worth of a
million dollars or more now let me help
you with this because sometimes people
get a bit confused or ignorant about
this
okay ignorant meaning they don't know
stupid is they know when they don't care
um
but
a net worth
a millionaire is not a
moral construct
it's not a oh that's too much money or
you no one should have that kind of
money
no one should be a billionaire no
christian should have that much money
it's not a moral construct millionaire
is a math equation and an accounting
formula
there's only one way to decide if
someone is a millionaire or a
billionaire only one
it's not a feeling it's not a political
statement it's a math thing
a millionaire is someone who has a net
worth of one million dollars or greater
your net worth is calculated only one
way
there's only one way to calculate net
worth
what you own
minus what you owe
assets minus liabilities
that is your net worth
period
simple
when that is one million dollars or more
what you own minus what you owe is one
million dollars or more you are a
millionaire it is not a million dollar
your income
i heard an idiot congressman the other
day a u.s congressman when he makes a
million dollars a year he's a
millionaire you're an idiot
that is not the definition of a
millionaire
a billionaire is someone who has a net
worth of a billion dollars and by the
way that's a lot more than a million
that's a thousand
million
very few billionaires
lots of millionaires
the
the process you use of building wealth
to become a millionaire will not make
you a billionaire
the forbes 400 the 400 wealthiest people
in america are all billionaires
none of them did it with their 401k
and almost all of our millionaires have
a huge 401k
huge roth ira and a paid for residence
and that's the primary pieces of their
net worth that we have interviewed and
that we've interviewed today for that
matter
so that's where millionaires really come
from your first one to 10 million
dollars of net worth will come from
those two sources primarily but you will
not become a billionaire saving in your
401k it is mathematically impossible
because you're limited on how much you
can put into your 401k
if you maxed out a 401k every single
year of your working life it would not
be a billion dollars no matter what the
growth rate was it's not going to get
there because that's a thousand
million millionaires do not have private
jets billionaires do
millionaires do not have seven homes
billionaires do
millionaires have two cars
one house maybe a beach condo
but very few of them have three or four
residences around the world
it's highly unusual those are
billionaire things that people do and
when you're a billionaire if you have a
10 million dollar jet
a uh 8 million dollar beach house
it's still a small percentage of your 1
000 million
think about it
and so it's not a big deal but but when
you have when you're when you have 10
million dollars you don't need a 10
million jet that's a bad idea
okay you see the difference so people
get confused about
emotionally what a billion areas versus
a millionaires one of the things we talk
about in this book that became a number
one
bestseller
baby steps millionaires where we discuss
how people have become millionaires how
you can become a millionaire i and the
difference is a billionaire i'm not
teaching you how to be a billionaire
the techniques that we teach you at
ramsey will make you a millionaire they
will not make you a billionaire
we don't teach you those techniques
most of those people are people that
owned a large business and took it and
or took it public and the stock from it
okay so the michael dell
the uh uh
you know chick-fil-a
uh walmart
these are families that are billionaires
several billionaires in some of those
families
and it's from the growth of a huge
business
more than it was simply saving and
getting the benefit of compound interest
jeff and stephanie are with us in
california what's your net worth
2.8 million cool give me a little
breakdown by category guys
800 000 in our primary residence
about 850 000 in rental properties
700 000 in various retirement accounts
250 and a taxable brokerage 185 000 in
cash which is mostly operating money for
our various businesses and 60 000 in our
kids 529 plants cool how old are you
guys
i'm 42. i'm 39. excellent how much of
the 2.8 did you inherit
i inherited a rental property which was
worth about 350 000 a few years ago but
my net worth was already about two
million dollars at that time so you're
not a millionaire because of inherited
money
no i'm not okay cool
all right 250 after all right got it and
uh what's been the range of your income
your best year and your worst year
uh
worst year probably about a hundred
shortly after i got out of law school
and our best year about 450.
okay cool very good all right and uh so
you've obviously got a law degree
and uh stephanie what's your degree in
um i collect certifications but my two
primary um income earning is uh i'm a
real estate broker and a paralegal got
it okay excellent very cool very cool so
what was your gpa guys
uh mine was 3.87 i'm i'm a nerd
i'm the free spirit i'm 3.42 but i only
got that because he was my tutor through
college ah
see what happened here
okay good job guys
way to go 42 years old and almost 3
million dollars well done y'all
how did you do it what was the biggest
key to success for y'all
um dave's advice was a big part of that
and i actually wanted to take this
opportunity dave to just say thank you
for changing my life
my dad introduced me to your material
back in 2013
and i
read some of your books and i was
listening to your podcast all the time
and i heard i heard you take a call
that really resonated with me a young
lawyer had called in
a couple years older than me at that
time he had a little bit of law school
loan
debt left and he he had a rental
property and you told him hey uh son
this is what you need to do you need to
sell that rental property take the money
and pay off your law school and stop
screwing around
and that really spoke to me and i i did
that and it put me on the right path and
with your teaching um it's changed my
life gabe so
thank you so much well thank you you
changed your life we're proud of you man
well done very well done there's a lot
of broke loggers out there and you're
not one of them good job
good job very very good no um no i'm not
and uh i i can't i just can't thank you
enough for not just changing my life but
changing my kid life my kids uh lives as
well you you do a great service for
everyone dave well we're honored i
appreciate that but again you're the one
that you're the hero you did this man
i'm proud of you thank you for for that
i'm glad you followed our stuff though i
like talking to baby steps millionaires
that's pretty cool man very good stuff
and and i got got started young very
very well done congratulations guys good
job very good job
so yeah when you read on
some stupid but social media thread or
something dave ramsey doesn't know how
to build wealth he's only helps you with
getting out of that
um you can just remember
you know some of these calls and it's
not to brag on me but the point is it
aggravates me because it makes people
think that the stuff we teach doesn't
make you wealthy and
we've probably made more millionaires
than anybody else in america right now
and um but but we did it by getting them
out of debt and teaching them to save
and invest in their retirement plan and
so it's not sexy or fun or get rich
quick and it doesn't match some bitcoin
scheme or some tick tock dance crap or
something like that that you guys are
getting you're getting your financial
advice from a 24 year old [ __ ]
i'm sorry but you know that's not
helpful this is the stuff that really
works and it aggravates me not because i
care about y'all bitching about me or
something that's not the point the point
is that then somebody like jeff and
stephanie don't become millionaires
because they listen to that garbage
instead of doing the stuff we teach
because this stuff works
this will make you wealthy that's why we
called the book baby steps millionaires
that's why it's
you know sold several hundred thousand
copies already because it freaking works
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour
on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today acts 4 12 salvation
is found in no one else for there is no
other name under heaven given to mankind
by which we must be saved
speaking of course of jesus
phillips brooks said christianity helps
us face the music even when we don't
like the tune
that's good i love that
uh it is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour here on the ramsey show christina
ellis ramsey personality is my co-host
today we're talking to real millionaires
people with a net worth of a million
dollars or more asking them how they did
it not asking your broke brother-in-law
his opinion lance is in indianapolis hey
lance what's your net worth
uh hi dave it's uh 1.8 million cool give
me a little breakdown by category sir
yeah um we have 1.3 million in different
kinds of retirement accounts uh our
house is probably worth 200 right now
we have liquid cash of 200 and a 529 of
a hundred thousand cool how old are you
i am 47 and my wife is 46. excellent how
much of the 1.8 did you inherit
um i think with uh with her mom parents
passing away and my grandmother we
probably inherit about 50 000
dollars total were you already
millionaires
yes we were okay so it didn't make you a
millionaire okay
no all right and uh what's your best
year working income your worst your
working income what's the range since
you've been well
yeah well i started in the philippines
in 1996 as a uh as a teacher and i only
earned 200 a month that's equivalent to
u.s dollars
uh when i came in the united states in
2002 probably the worst year was my
intern which i have forty thousand
dollars a year and my best year was last
year when i hit 185 000 because of kobe
do you have a lot of overtimes and
everything like that yeah what do you do
what's your career i'm a pharmacist i'm
a pharmacist excellent okay all right
very good and so you are you were you a
us citizen or were you born in the
philippines
i was born in the philippines actually i
was there at the dave ramsey show uh ten
years ago yesterday to we had our debt
free screen 10 years ago there
uh so since then
uh i was a citizen uh we became citizen
in 2017.
excellent wow good for you so proud of
you yep way to go man that's awesome
stuff interesting statistic folks you
are four times more likely to become a
millionaire if you come here from
another country legally than if you were
born here
because they actually believe that this
is the best place on the planet that's
why they came here
and some of you grow up here and sit
around in whine
instead of going and getting this done
and so that's not unusual at all by the
way and uh very very interesting stuff
all right let's go to william in
houston and william what's your net
worth
um
one million two thousand dollars
one million bucks a flat i love it good
for you right there you made it over the
wire all right so what is your breakdown
on that million dollars
so our house is worth about 450 000 uh
retirement we have about 440 000 in it
uh ninety five thousand dollars in cash
and then fifteen thousand fifteen to
twenty thousand dollars and just
valuables how old are you
we are i mean my for both 32. all right
young millionaires cool and what's your
best working year income and your worst
working year income
so when we were both working who i think
our best year was 225 000 but now it's
just me so
about 125 000 gotcha okay and what do
you do for a living
so i'm a nurse practitioner and my
wife's a chemical engineer all right
very good very good
you think this can still be done if
you're 24
out there listening yes
absolutely it's i
i wish i was as smart as my wife when i
was 24 because uh it really wasn't for
her we wouldn't be in this position but
um
no we uh
it's absolutely possible you just gotta
have a game plan so if you could go back
to your 24 year old self what would you
tell him
oh god don't be an idiot
i think that's universal right there
you know
i mean
focus in school don't is college is not
for fun it's you know for school and um
don't go into debt like don't buy a new
car don't again don't don't be normal
you know be a little bit abnormal yeah
be weird because you are weird you're a
32 year old millionaire way to go dude
way to go all right so let's review we
had a 1.25 million uh 1.6 million 1.76
million 2.8 million 1.8 million and 1
million 34 years old 59 years old 48
years old 42 years old 47 and 32 years
old engineer engineer engineer real
estate lawyer pharmacist nurse engineer
number one and by the way
occupation of millionaires is engineer
number two is accountant number three is
teacher
number four
is uh
manager in business
uh number five is lawyer
medical doctors don't even make the top
five they're number six
they're notoriously stupid with money
like a lot of artists are but they are
the number six highest likelihood of
millionaires but they earn a lot of
money so it's good it's very good that's
the real world 79 of millionaires
according to the largest study airtight
research of millionaires ever done
79 received zero inheritance
another five percent received a small
inheritance like we heard today fifteen
hundred dollars
something like that that did not
mathematically cause someone to become a
millionaire another five percent
received a substantial inheritance after
they were already millionaires like we
had a 250 000 a day or 50 000 a day okay
after they were already millionaires so
again
79 zero
five percent with not enough to make you
a millionaire five percent got of
inheritance after they were already
millionaires 79 and five and five is 89
90
of america's millionaires 9 out of 10
are not millionaires because of
inherited money
so when you hear that crap from your
leftist idiot friend who's about wealth
inequality they are
absolutely wrong
why is that a big deal because when you
spread lies that steal hope from people
it causes them to not go out into the
marketplace and win i can't be a
millionaire because all millionaires
inherited their money the only way i'm
gonna be a millionaire is get it from
the rich people so i gotta elect
somebody who takes it from the rich
people and gives it to me see this is
stupid but stuff and it's a narrative
that has to be squashed because it's a
lie
it's it needs to be killed because it's
it's this war on success the
it's just not true that's the other part
of it it's just statistically not right
so there's that i can't stand hope
stealers i'm about giving hope yeah and
i mean these stories today it's all
about intentionality they walked through
a plan they were super intentional and
then they made it happen
they
yeah they were intentional they you
plant corn corn grows whoa what happened
who knew you know
you know that's just that's the thing
and it's so funny
and you know i put money in my 401k
every one of them
every one of them
had you know seven eight hundred
thousand a million two in their 401k
roth iras every one of them every one of
them today that we talked to had a paid
for house or almost a paid for house
and that was in their equation i'm not
buying real estate i'm gonna rent my
whole life well you're not gonna be a
millionaire then because statistically
the two things that make people
millionaires most of the time is you're
putting money in your 401k plan and you
get your house paid off there's some
other stuff you can do but that's the
two big ones if you ignore those you're
not gonna get there bozo why is this
hard
find the
data and follow the data the breadcrumbs
are right there hansel and gretel do it
you know it's just not hard yeah you
just got to make a plan and stick with
it none of these people were it wasn't
an accidental process they weren't like
oh whoa i'm a millionaire what happened
who knew
none of them were surprised
yep
and they all believe the next generation
can do it they don't believe it's over
so they haven't given up on the american
economy is rigged
no it's not
it's not rigged one thing for sure you
can't get rich people to agree on
nothing
they can't get together and rig it
because they can't agree with each other
so it's pretty simple y'all you can
there's plenty out there for you and we
want you to go win
we really want you to go win
baby steps millionaires an hour good job
christina
good job austin ben zach andrew james
kelly in the booth i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you